So today we're going to wrap up the
lecture from uh last time on uh
stochastic uh uh stoastic dynamic
programming and in particular the
infinite horizon extension to it and
then we're going to move to the next
topic which is that of closed loop
optimal control in continuous time which
should be a pretty interesting lecture
as we as you would see. Now going back
to the discussion from last time, the
place where we left it off is we define
the extension of stoastic optimal
control to an infinite horizon. What
happened? I want to know about a joke.
>> I said four restaurants on my
>> four restaurants and I hope that at
least one of those is Italian. [snorts]
>> Is it? No.
Minus five. So yeah, you can minus five
points. Anyways, all right. So we set up
the infin
uh optimal control problem, infinitizen
mdp problem and then we discussed how
the notion of a bellman equation extends
to that setting in a specific form
represented by the fixed point infinite
horizon of Bellman equation whereby now
the optimal value function. We talked
how influence setting typically people
uh reason in terms of rewards as opposed
to costs. So now the object we are
trying to compute is not the optimal
cost but the optimal reward also
referred to as optimal value function.
So the optimal value function satisfies
a fixed point equation whereby v star x
the optimal value for the problem that
starts at state x is equal to the
maximum over use of the immediate reward
plus the average
optimal uh reward to go where the
summation over tx prime xu is
essentially averaging the optimal value
function from the perspective of the
next stage with respect to the all
possible realization of the state at the
next stage given that we are in state X
and we choose control U. And then we saw
that if you are interested not in the
optimal value function but in the value
of a given policy pi. So basically how
much reward a given policy pi occurs
over an infinite horizon starting from
state x. Well, uh this quantity referred
to as v subscript pi of x can be
computed as a solution to uh the
equation portrayed here which in the
case of a finite state space amounts to
solving a linear system of equations
into the components of the value
function vector. Remember that V of
X is the value for a specific state X
and if you have a 10 possible states
then you will have 10 different values
one for each possible value of the
state. Does it make sense?
And then the additional twist that we
introduced last time is
what if we introduce the notion of a Q
function that conceptually takes on the
capture the concept of starting at X
using control Q and then using the
optimal policy from the next stage
onward.
If that is the case, so if we reason in
terms of the Q function, Qstar function,
then the QST star function actually
satisfy
um an equation that is very similar to
the BMAN equation
whereby the optimal Q function is equal
to the reward, the current reward plus
the average of the uh maximum Q function
maximized over U prime.
We've uh we derived this um equation
last time so I'm not going to go through
it again
but the bottom line is that if you have
an infinite horizon MDP then we have an
analog of the Bman equation in the
infinite horizon setting which is
represented by a fixed point equation
either for the value function or the for
the Q function. We discussed last time
the notion of a Q function is part
particularly useful in learning
settings. We'll come back to it in three
four lectures.
So now the next question is uh how do we
solve the fixed point equation? So this
is an equation in which the unknown is
the function B of X. We know R because
we specified we are in a setting whereby
we assume that we know the transition
probabilities. So we know R and T but we
don't know V star. So how do we solve
for v star or
how do we solve for the optimal policy?
I mean in general you are interested in
the value function but most importantly
you are interested in the optimal policy
because that's the object you use in
order to control your system.
So
at a very high level there are two
settings that we we're going to address
in this class and both are extremely
important. The first setting which is
the setting of the remainder of this
lecture is the setting where we know the
transition function t it has been given
to us and we know the reward function.
So in this setting where all the problem
data is known the only unknown is the
value function and the optimal policy.
There are two broad classes of
algorithms. One referred to as value
iteration and the other one referred to
as policy iteration.
It's important you familiarize with
these two concepts because they become
especially important as we move to the
learning setting. Specifically, in the
learning setting, some of the problem
data is not assumed to be known. For
example, we may not know or have the
right access to the transition
probabilities t.
So, how do we solve for the value
function
and how do we solve for the optimal
policy? There are essentially two types
of methods. The first type is referred
to as model based. The idea is that you
infer from data all the problem data for
example the transition probabilities and
once you've done so then you're back
into
this setting where all the problem data
is known and then you can use value
iteration or policy iteration or you
just go directly
to the quantity that you care about to
the optimal value function and the
optimal policy those are meth those
methods are referred to as model three.
So in this class we will cover both
modelbased and model free methods. They
have different pros and cons. Uh we'll
cover those in two to three weeks from
now.
But for now we focus on the first
setting the one where all the problem
data is known.
And the algorithms as we will see are
relatively simple conceptually. So let's
start from with the value iteration
algorithm. The very iteration algorithm
is quite intuitive. The idea is that you
set up an iteration where you
iteratively
reoptimize the fix and point Bman
equation in a style that is very similar
to the Bellman equation we saw in
discrete time setting. You start from an
initial condition for the value
function. Maybe just a zero vector. So
you assume that the value for each
possible state is equal to zero. You
apply one step belman equation for many
many many times and then you hope that
you will converge to something.
It turns out that this algorithm is
indeed guaranteed to converge to the
optimal value function v star. So for
any initial condition
the iterates VKS will converge to the
optimal vstar of X.
If you have no clue about uh what the
value function is, you can just start by
assigning zero to all possible states.
Of course, if you have some guess about
what the
uh optimal value function is, you should
use that guess. You're guaranteed to
converge anyways. But of course, the
convergence rate is much faster if you
start from a good guess. So what is the
intuition behind the value iteration?
Remember that we are in infinite horizon
setting. So let's assume that you start
at infinity
and then so assume okay let me rephrase
it. Let's assume that you instead of
having an infinite horizon problem you
have a finite horizon problem but where
the horizon is very very long like three
trillion years. Then you start from
three trillion years in the future and
then you start doing backward recussion
many many times until today.
Well, that really approximate the
infinite horizon setting and that's
intuition behind the value iteration
algorithms for the infinite horizon
problem. And it turns out that in the
stationary setting once you apply the
Bman equation many many times you
converge to a steady state solution
which is the solution to the fixed point
equation that I showed before.
Does it roughly make sense?
Of course, there should be a proof to
prove this statement. It's not entirely
obvious. I'm just giving you you had an
intuition. Yeah.
>> So are you saying that this is like
essentially analogous to a kind of like
dynamic program but like a very long
>> Yeah. So we spent half an hour to
explain the infinite horizon setting by
the end of the day we're still doing
finite horizon computations. Yes.
But if you do it many many times then
you're guaranteed to converge to the
solution for the infinite horizon
setting.
Yep. That's exactly right.
And of course once you have computed the
optimal value function then you can
backtrack the optimal control by just
solving for the maximization over the
use and now you know v star. So actually
this optimization problem can be solved.
>> In advance how many times we have to
repeat to that will actually
>> no unfortunately it's a synthetic we'll
come with I'll show you another
algorithm that in some cases actually
has a finite uh horizon convergence
guarantees. So then you're raising a
good point though. When do we stop
um
where is it
when [snorts] do you stop value
iteration? In a way it's similar to
uh
it's similar to the situation where
we're doing a gradient based methods for
optimization. So for example, if the
difference between a VK and VK plus one
across all of the states is not too
large, that could be a good termination
criterion or maybe after an arbitrary
number of iterations, say 20,000, just
call it a day. So there are different um
uh ways to terminate the algorithm.
There are there are of course a bunch of
much more sophisticated analysis that
also give you an error bound in terms of
how much you might be far off the
optimal value function after a certain
number of steps. But in general
termination is not obvious. But you are
guaranteed that if you do it many many
times you converge to the value function
optimal function.
And there is an analog of it also for Q
functions is essentially taking the
fixed point equation for the optimal Q
function and then iterate
analogous intuition
policy iteration. I'm not spending too
much time in iteration policy iteration
because we will revisit these two
algorithms through a learning based lens
which is ultimately what we are mostly
interested in in this class. For now,
I'm just giving you the overarching uh
ideas and concepts and terminology.
Policy iteration takes a different
approach. Rather than operating in value
space, that is optimizing over the value
functions themselves. It operates in
policy space that is optimized directly
in the space of policies, which kind of
makes sense because at the end of the
day, we're mostly interested in the
optimal closed loop policy. The value
function is more of an intermediary
concept that allow us to compute the
optimal policy.
So the idea of a policy evaluation is as
follows. It's still an iterative
algorithm. So you start from initial
condition and then you apply your
insight into MDP and optimal control and
you come try to come up with a better
policy and then you continue iterating
until after you get to a good policy.
Specifically, how does it work? Let's
assume that you start from a given
policy pi k. So here k does not refer to
the time stage
but is the iteration counter.
So k stands for the k iteration in the
policy iteration algorithm. So you start
from a policy pk.
Then what the policy iteration algorithm
does is uh a two-step procedure where
first we compute the value of the policy
pi k for each possible state x by using
the uh bellman equation that allows you
to derive the value of for the val
function for a given policy pi k.
[snorts] So you compute the V
of pi K.
This is the same equation I had in the
previous slides. Note that here I'm
computing the value associated to
specific policy. So there is no
optimization. There is no maximization
with respect to U. So this equation at
least notionally is easy to solve. We
know R. We know the transition
probabilities. This is just numbers. So
this is just a linear equations in the
uh value function v pi. So you could
solve it as a large scale linear system
in the unknowns that are represented by
the value of the policy when starting
from each possible state x= 1 x2 and so
on and so forth.
>> Yeah
on the right side pan
you mean?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. That's a typo
>> here. No. So here, that's not a typo.
Here exactly what we had here. So if
you're given a policy pi the value so
the cumulative sum of rewards discounted
with the discounting factor gamma is
given by solving the equation here.
>> How can the looks like the right hand
side depend on the left hand side?
>> Yeah this is a linear system of
equations. So you would collect
everything on the left hand side. Here
you'll have your constant terms and then
you you will solve for the vector v. V
of x is essentially a vector is v of 0 v
of I mean assume that x can take on four
values 0 1 2 and three. It will be v of
uh v of 0 v of 1 v of 2 v of three.
Make sense? This makes it a bit more
explicit.
So, so after you have done that, then
you have a big step. So, the first step
is referred to as policy evaluation
because we are evaluating the value
associated to given policy pi. The
policy improvement step is where the
magic happens.
So, now that we have
computed the value for a given policy
pi. We try to come up with a better
policy and to do so we apply a one step
of the bellman equation. So we set the
value we set the control for the
revised policy P of K + one. This will
be iteration k + one as the control that
minimize the sorry the maximizes since
we're in the reward setting the stage
wise reward. So the current reward plus
the
um reward starting from the next
stage
approximated by vp v pi k.
So basically we take a one step bman
equation to try to improve the action
that I should be taking a state x.
[snorts]
So this is not the optimal action. The
optimal action will be the one that you
would be computing if you were to plug
in bar star the optimal value function.
But you use VPK as a sort of placeholder
that awfully allows you to derive a
better action. The optimal action is the
one that you will compute if you were to
use Var. We are not using Var because we
know Var yet. We use a surrogate which
is VPK.
So the key result and of course there
should be there should be a proof here
is not entirely obvious is that the
value for the new policy is that greater
than or equal to the value for the
previous policy. So actually you are you
are getting into a policy that is
better. Remember that we're in reward
setting. So the higher the value the
happier you are.
[snorts] And even better the inequality
is strict if by k is suboptimal is not
the optimal policy.
If you found the optimal policy great if
you not found the optimal policy you
know the policy the next iteration is
going to be better.
So going back to the question from your
colleague about finite finite
time guarantees assume that you have a
finite number of states. So x can take
on the value 0 1 2 3 4 and a finite time
a finite number of controls.
Do you think that this algorithm knowing
this property do you think that this
algorithm is going to converge in a
final number of steps?
Yes. No.
Yes. Because essentially if you have a
finite number of states and finite
number of controls there are finitely
many policies different ways that you
can permute the control with respect to
all the different states since you know
that at every step of this algorithm you
are always going to strictly improve
the value of a given policy. There are
so many times that you can improve the
value until you reach the optimal value.
So indeed policy iteration converges a
finite number of steps in the setting of
uh fixed number of I mean um finite
number of states and finite number of
controls.
Of course what you should prove and
again all these proves proofs are
provided in great detail in the books
from Bertikas is the monotonic
improvement property we have here.
So in a nutshell with value iteration we
estimate the optimal value function and
we then compute we can compute the
optimal policy [snorts] through the Bman
equation once uh we know the optimal
value function. In policy iteration we
start with a random policy and we
interly improve it until convergence to
an optimal policy. Of course all of this
requires the model NDP to be known. In
particular, it assumes that we know
the transition probabilities here.
Otherwise, for example, you wouldn't be
able to solve for the V by K quantities.
>> Yeah.
>> Explain why you believe the policy
should improve each step.
Well, I mean you are making essentially
a more informed decision that exploit
the structure of uh the problem where
you not only look at the immediate gains
but also the the future gains and is
essentially a surrogate of what those
future gains could look at. So it's not
100% clear what that necessarily brings
to an improvement but I think that
intuitively stands to reason.
Great. So this is all I want to say
about the infinite horizon MDPS. We will
revisit them at great length when we
talk about learning based control. So my
main goal here was just to set the
terminology for the infinite pro
infinite horizon instantiation of uh
stoastic optional control problems and
really fix some foundational ideas in
terms of uh how the bellman equation
applies into an infinite horizon setting
and how we can solve for it through two
main methodologies namely very iteration
and policy iteration. We'll come back to
all of these in um three weeks or so.
So what we're going to do now is we go
back to the deterministic setting
but we explore
the complimentary dimension whereby
instead instead of reasoning in finite
time we reason in continuous time.
So going back to our agenda. So we have
uh discussed at length this branch.
So finite horizon closed loop optimal
control through the lens of the uh Bman
equation and dynamic programming. We've
looked at specific instantiations of uh
the DS of uh dynamic programming
including RQ LQRQ.
So now we are moving to the setting
where by now time is a continuous
variable. So this is useful because
sometimes problems are more naturally
framed in continuous time and sometimes
the policies that are derived from the
continuous time formulation are a bit
cleaner and also a bit easier to
implement. So we'll see.
And so what we will derive is the
continuous time extension of the dynamic
programming equations referred to as
Hamto Yakobi Belman and Hamyakcomi E is
equation and then we're going to use
those techniques to solve the two
problems of importance LQR and
continuous time. This looks like all
this class there is one problem we can
solve is LQR. I mean LQR is also a
pedagogical is important is also a
pedagogical tool.
And then another very interesting class
of problems related to rechibility
analysis. Actually this is a I mean MQR
is very important. Ribility analysis is
also quite important uh is what we use
for example to deise
um collision avoidance policies for
autonomous cars or for airplanes and so
on and so forth.
All right. So the previous lecture we
focus on the discrete time setting. In
this lecture, we focus on the continuous
time uh setting. We will discuss how the
dynamic programming approach leads to
its continuous time counterpart referred
to as the Hamakobi Bman equation and
Hamington is equation. We'll use the
Hamito Yakobi Belman equation to solve
the LQR problem in continuous time and
then we'll use the Hamito Yakobi is
equations to address the rich analysis
problem that I will define later on.
So just to make sure that we are uh on
the same page. So so far this is the pro
problem formulation we've been focusing
on in the context of closed loop optimal
control discrete dynamics and a discrete
cost.
Now we go back to the continuous time
formulation. And it is actually the one
we started with when we were talking
about direct optimization. Uh when we
were talking about open loop optimal
control where now the dynamics are
written in terms of a differential
equation x dot= f of x
and the cost is now still an additive
cost but instead of summation we have an
integral.
So this lecture will be quite
interesting.
It's also quite deep. So stay you know
attentive and also there will be some uh
changes of notation across the lecture
for very specific reasons that I will
discuss. So uh be focused. The plus
though is that actually this is a pretty
interesting I mean all lectures of
course are super interesting but this
one I mean personally I find it
particularly interesting.
In particular, we're going to look at a
more general setting that will become
clear later why we do so. Uh
that is interesting in its own right and
also quite kind of complimentary to what
we've done so far. Specifically, we now
assume that in addition to everything I
said so far,
our dynamics are also influenced by a
disturbance term DT.
So when we were talking about discrete
time stoastic formulation, D was just a
random variable
generated according to some probability
distribution. Here we're in
deterministic setting.
But D
encodes the notion of another player.
Think of it as nature that is trying to
interfere with our objectives.
These are the so-cal adversarial
formulations for optimal control that
are very useful to come up with control
policies that are really robust. No
matter what nature throws at you within
some limit, you're still guaranteed if
you use techniques that we're going to
explain to achieve your objectives. Of
course, the price for it is that
sometimes this policies can be quite
conservative because they had to protect
you from the worst case that nature can
throw at you.
But you see that all these things are
complimentary, right? So in many
settings you prefer a more stoastic
formulation. Uh average realization of
uh what happens is fun enough with you.
But for example, when your life is at
stake, probably you take a more
pessimistic view of what could happen.
So you're not happy anymore. We're just
reasoning about averages. Actually, you
want to protect yourself on the worst
case. So that's what formulation is
doing. Player one,
we control you to is you. So you're
controlling you to maximize J. So here
is a little bit of a difference in
objective. So now J even though it's
written as J plays the role of a reward.
So you want to maximize J. You want to
make J as large as possible. Think of it
about your wealth.
Player two
which use control DT will aim to
minimize J subject to the joint system
dynamics. So U and D are coupled through
the joint system dynamics. So the the
state the revolution of the state depend
depends on both u and d through the
function f and a cost g also depends on
u and d. We'll see some examples later.
But does this make sense? We have
generalized a setting where now we have
a disturbance
which is not just uh uh any disturbance
is actually an active player that is
trying to damage you.
One example that we will release later
and I also mentioned it before
is that of the
homicidal chauffeur.
So this is a person. So that's you
player one.
And here there is a car.
Well, I mean my drawing skills are quite
limited. Anyway, this is a car. Okay.
And so the the pedestrian
can move in any direction,
but the speed is in general lower. So it
top speed is in general lower than the
top speed of the car.
The car
is faster than a pedestrian but it has
constraints on its motion. Particularly
a car cannot move laterally. That's why
parking is annoying. If you can move
laterally, I mean for most cars you
cannot move laterally.
So that's player two.
So UT
is essentially the sequence of controls
for your legs. in order to get out of
the way for the car. DT is the sequence
of controls for the car in terms of
throttle and steering to try to hit you.
Now the question is
what is the set of joint states? of
initial conditions for the pedestrian
and initial condition for the car so
that uh
you can survive no matter how hard the
car is trying to hit you
just to have a little bit of intu
distance is not it matters but it's not
the only thing that matters geometry and
curvature also matter quite a bit so if
you want to save yourselves intuitively.
What is the best way to initialize your
position? So the car is here and there's
a top down view. So this is the car.
Okay. So here there are the wheels
and can maneuver in this plane, right?
And can go backward
and you want to survive. Where should
they drop you?
here
>> or here.
>> Here. Exactly. Exactly. So now you
understand the differential games
because
even though you are slower since the car
it's it's faster but it's also carvature
constraint. uh what we end up doing will
be start to constantly trying to circle
around you but you're smart enough to
keep the car going around you. Of course
if you are unfortunately dropped here
most likely there is not much you can do
and no matter how you maneuver you at
some point it's going to the car is
going to hit you. Then the question is
how do we formulate all of that in a
mathematical form so that we can
actually find the controls use D and
then the state the subset of the state
space with a guarantee that if you start
there then nothing is going to happen to
you. Why are this problem formulation
useful and then I'll get to you is for
example for collision avoidance uh
scenario say that uh you want to develop
a collision avoidance policy for an
aircraft and you want to be absolutely
sure that other aircraft are not going
to collide with you. I mean in reality
the other aircraft most likely are not
trying to kill you intentionally but you
know the other pilot maybe are
distracted. So uh if you lack a better
model for them, you just model them as
adversarial. You know that if you really
have a policy that allow you to save
yourself under the worst possible
action, then if the other pilot is
distracted, is drunk or maybe is really
trying to hit you, then you're going to
survive. Yeah.
>> Oh yes.
So it turns out and this will become
clear later
that uh
when we reason about uh closed loop
optimal control and continuous time
particularly with disturbances these are
problems referred to as differential
games they're games because there are
two players differential because the
actions between the two players are
constrained by the differential
dynamics.
In those settings, we like to think
about the final time as zero and the
initial time t0 as some negative time in
the past. So view of t0 as - 5 - 6. This
is really notation and this is a typical
notation used in the differential game
literature. So it's really notation.
There is nothing deeper here. But it's
good that you point it out. So for this
lecture, the final time will be denoted
by zero.
So the terminal condition will be at
zero and we start in the past. Yeah.
>> Use this formulation to modelic
environments. Why do we assume that um
the stoastic element is univers
like
could be distracted in a way that goes
farther away from us and therefore
>> yeah I mean this is just an adversarial
formulation and the problem remains
deterministic. So there is no
stoasticity here. But you could also
consider a stoastic formulation.
Actually ax which is the next generation
collision avoidance system is built upon
um a stoastic formulation. And then of
course you can capture some notion of
adversal behavior through the
probability distribution that defines
the realization of the random variable.
These are different modeling choices.
What I'm telling you is g I'm giving you
a menu. I mean that's the point of this
class of different control methodologies
and how to solve for them but then I
mean you're still the agentic agent that
has to decide uh what to do at least for
the foreseeable future.
Now what interesting part and here is
when you have to apply your brain is the
problem as described here is not fully
specified meaning what type of
information does player two have access
to in order to respond to what you do
what you what you do and there are a few
formulations
the most intuitive one but also a very
bad one is that I as player one declare
my full control sequence from time t0
all the way to the final time zero.
Player two gets to see that and then it
optimize it optimizes its own optimal
control sequence dt. Of course, this
gives an enormous advantage to player
two because it it knows exactly what
you're going to do between now and the
final time. So this formulation
typically make the problem uh very
simple because essentially uh the nested
optimization between what the player
does and the player one gets very easily
decoupled. So you just uh look at all
possible control actions that uh uh you
could entail and then I look how to
optimally respond to them and then I
solve the optimization problem and done
computationally cheap but very realistic
very conservative because you need you
give an enormous advantage to the other
player. The one we look into is a bit
more sophisticated.
So here
the player two gets to see what player
one has done up until now. So it does
not have an anticipatory
skill of also seeing what you'll be
doing in the future. So it's a constant
game between player one and player two
that player one make a choice, player
two see that and then they keep
iterating in closed loop. Does it make
sense? It's a little bit of a difference
but it's very profound.
So the other agent meaning player two
acts based on state and control
trajectory up to current time.
Note and the notation is that the set of
strategies we look at are those
strategies whereby we get to see you
from time to zero up to the current
time. Note the player two still has a
little bit of advantage because it gets
to see first what you do now and then a
reply. Think about chess. I mean usually
white has an advantage because it moves
first. So here player two still has an
advantage because the current time t you
player one make a move and then I make
my move. So I get to react.
So actually the inverse of chess
actually.
So does it make sense? So this is the
class of strategies we're going to focus
on. Those that do not anticipate which
of course will be invisible in practice.
what the player one will do. So is is
very is much closer to the type of
operations you will see in practice.
[snorts]
Any questions here?
This is important. So if you have
equations on this part.
Okay. So if you have
uh studied game theory, this is game
theory on steroids because now there is
a game aspect. But now you also have to
think about the differential evolution
of dynamics which makes the problem even
more interesting because now there are
geometric considerations you have to
consider and so on.
So the problem we want to solve then is
as follows.
We want to solve a minimax problem
whereby the player one will tend to
maximize its outcome. Again here we're
in a setting where we view J as a
reward. So you player you are player one
and you try to optimize your outcome and
player two will aim to minimize it
subject to the system dynamics F.
So we want to find a U that makes the
cost as high as possible under the most
damaging disturbance D.
>> Make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Semantics a little bit, but I'm curious
on a prior slide you said that player
two has been managed. And I'm struggling
to see how player two would have the
advantage when player one would be the
one first in this structure
because essentially I get to see what
you do
right and so I if I know for example
there are two cars. So this is player
one
and this is player two.
In a dynamic situation, say that player
two wants to hit you.
So,
and you're player two.
So, say that you know that at time t
player one is going to move in this
direction. This is a very useful
information to you because you know that
action these directions are not useful
to you to damage player one. Actually
going this direction is uh advantageous.
So you see how having access to what the
other person is going to do basically
allows you to rule out actions that are
not going to be maximally damaging and
instead focus on the ones that are
maximally damaging.
Does it make sense?
>> This problem are we solving for the
worst disturbance or the optimal
control?
>> Both.
>> Yeah. That's why it's a minimax term. We
want to um
uh essentially you're solving I mean at
the end of the day you care about you
but in doing so you uh solve
simultaneously with respect to both the
optimal disturbance and the optimal
control. So you try to find the u that
makes the cost as I said as high as
possible under the worst possible
disturbance t and you compute both of
them. Of course, in practice, unless you
take the role of player two, uh you're
going to use the control U.
>> Yeah. So, this is a abstract notation
that says that we pick that is only
those disturbance D that are not
anticipated.
So, they can only react to what player
one has done
up until now. So it doesn't have is what
I was saying before doesn't have access
to what player one will do in the
future.
>> The time history of player two
instantaneous
>> that's right. So it's only an
instantaneous advantage.
Great. So that said so the problem
formulation here is quite sophisticated.
Yeah
>> already. But why is why is the uh player
one or the controller you trying to
maximize cost instead of minimize it?
>> No no what I said is that in this
specific setting don't view G as a cost
view G as a reward.
>> Oh
>> this is just terminology. So here this
there is nothing deep here. So we are in
a word setting but they're using J
notation because unfortunately that's
what the community uses
around like min and max like find the
minimum possible disturbance and then
find a control that would like given
that disturbance be the most optimal.
>> No actually to give the advantage to
play so the the fact that we're defining
problem as a minimat with the
disturbance as the outer optimizer is
not by chance. This is exactly what
gives the disturbance the advantage
whereas with what the controller is
doing.
>> I guess advantage.
>> Yeah. By placing it as a um an outer
minimizer. That's right.
Okay. So all great questions. So now
yes.
>> Yeah. So that's why advantage is only
instantaneous.
>> Okay.
>> It's a slight advantage.
>> Okay. But even at the beginning
[clears throat] doesn't want an
advantage knowing already the same state
of being
the right know
it
well I think
this business is best interpreted when
uh you are at a general time t and so
you have some history of x p2 [snorts]
and x1 one one towel. So in this sitor
just a general time t
having access to the information
including time t basically strictly
speaking you have more information right
because you had additional bit of
information at time t and having more
information is is always more useful.
Does it make sense? In general more
information is better than less
information. So we can also justify it
in that way.
Great. All right. So how do we solve
this problem?
as usual uh dynamic programming and uh
principal optimality.
So the solution is as follows.
We decompose the um
the objective
in the two pieces. immediate reward plus
reward to go.
And remember from when we were talking
about the principal optimality that
there is no loss in optimality if we
restrict the search over the optimal
controlled signals to only those
controlled signals that results from the
concatenation of uh optimal tails
and then immediate rewards.
So this is represented notionally by the
drawing here where I'm showing that if I
give you the uh optimal solution for the
tail problem starting at time t plus t a
state xt plus delta t.
You don't need to reason about control
sequences to do something else starting
from point B3 or point B2 or point B1.
you just concatenate the initial segment
with the optimal tails and you just
compare the three controlled sequence
that arise from these concatenations.
So here I'm enforcing the principal
optimality in this decomposition of the
uh cost. So here I'm not doing anything
new. I'm really applying the principal
optimality in the same shape and form
that we discussed a few lectures um ago.
So the point is that the problem here
which is the original formulation h of x
here as usual is the terminal cost
can be rewritten as the cost whereby I
concatenate optimal tails with
um in a way transition. So view
basically this integral between t and
plus delta t as a very short transition
into the new time.
So if you have fully grasped the
principal optimality then this should be
quite uh clear. If this doesn't look
quite clear it means that you haven't
analyzed yet the principal optimality.
So try to do a little bit more thinking
about it.
As I said a couple of lectures ago, the
principle of optimality is such that
when you see the first time I think it's
obvious after a while becomes very
confusing and after a little while then
becomes obvious again. So when I see it
it's obvious to me but you know there
was a time where it was not so obvious
to me. So I'm trying to say it takes a
little bit of time for you to really
internalize it.
Anyway, so assuming that uh um we buy
this step where we uh enforce the
principle optimality. So we just say
that we look
a control and disturbance sequences that
are the results of the concatenation of
optimal tails and um a first uh uh bit
of control between time t plus delta t.
how we can massage this uh expression
into something that leads me to
something that is computable.
So view delta t as a small time
increment.
By the way, this stuff mathematically is
very complicated. So if you were to do
it super super cleanly, it would be a
bit complicated. Here I'm just giving
you the main intuition.
This is probably one of the most complex
you know concepts in optimal control.
So the integral can be approximated as g
* delta t. So over very very small
interval delta t you can view the
function g almost a constant value. So
the integral is simply equal to the
integrant time the uh time difference
delta t
xt plus delta t can be written according
to one step discretization x as xt plus
delta t f of xud. I mean we have done
this many many times
which means that we can approximate
the optimal cost to go from a time t
plus delta t
I'll rewrite it here
with a once uh first order tus
approximation
by this becomes j of xt
t plus gradient of j with respect to x
time x of t + delta t minus x of t.
But this is equal to
delta t f of x
plus
partial d with respect to t * delta t.
job. This is a simple step
here. There is the cracks of the
problem.
The most difficult thing to swallow in
this entire lecture.
So we have JJ. So nothing new here. We
have approximated the integral uh with
just this quantity that we have here. we
have substituted the j of x plus delta t
comma d plus delta t with its tailor
series expansion. Okay. So we have it um
uh we have it here
but now the part that is tricky
is that it is instantaneous scale. So
now I have removed
u and d as a function of time over a
continuous interval.
Now d and u are evaluated exactly at the
time t.
So at the instantano scale the
disturbance is not choosing a a a whole
trajectory anymore. It is choosing a
reaction to the current control.
So the nested structure changes from the
outer player picking a function
anticipating the optimal response to at
each instant one player moves and the
other reacts. So this becomes closer to
chess actually. So that's why we swap
the order between mean and max to
preserve the advantage related to the
disturbance. That's a part that hard to
swallow. It would require a much deeper
proof. But the idea is that essentially
we're trying to be consistent with our
assumption that player two is um um
the one that has the advantage.
You get a control and then the student
reacts optimally.
I saw the problem stand changes from min
max to max min. So
this is not entirely obvious and I don't
want to spend it too much time on it
because otherwise it will be an entire
lecture on it. So I'm trying to give you
as much intuition as possible here. It
might be a little bit cloudy what is
happening. But the point being is that
in order to be consistent with the fact
that player two has an advantage, we
have when we uh the problem boils down
to instantaneous optimization swap the
notion of a minimum maximum maximum
minimum.
This is this is the hardest part to
swallow.
So it's a little bit of a step where you
have to trust your instructor. But at
least
uh trust me in the sense that what we're
doing here is try to be consistent with
the assumption that player two has the
uh advantage. So the idea is that uh
your player one will fix you
and then D gets to choose the the
possible best response and then you try
to pick the U such that uh for that U D
has the less damaging response
but player two has an advantage because
it gets to see what you do.
Okay. So assuming we agree for this step
and from now on actually the lecture
will be downhill. So it's uphill because
the formulation of differential games is
a little bit complicated because we have
this business of non anticipatory
strategies that is
relatively natural but not
straightforward. it gets to the peak
where this swapping between min max and
max mean is a bit uh uh you know uh is
it is deep as a concept but then it gets
downhill from now on. Yep.
>> Sorry. So why couldn't we write max men
sense?
>> Because here this mean max and this max
mean has a bit of different uh uh
interpretation. Here we're doing nested
optimization over the space of control
sequences. Here we're doing a nested
optimization over space of instantanous
control. So within this terminology
actually turns out that to give the
super an advantage it has to be part of
the outer uh approximation. That's the
part where
it it [clears throat] can be understood
but it would require a bit of a deeper
discussion to be super rigorous. So
that's what I'm saying. So it's a little
bit of one of the few parts in the class
where you have to trust your instructor.
The most important thing though is that
you understand the problem formulation
and then you understand the uh final
algorithm that we're going to derive.
That's the most important thing here.
I'm just providing a little bit of
intuition about what that algorithm is
coming from. The specific steps are not
so essential.
Anyway, assuming we agree on this,
then we arrive here. So J does not
depend on U. So I can bring and D so I
can bring it out of the optimization. So
these two terms cancel.
Great. Then I can also cancel these
terms that the T.
Okay. And then I get to the celebrated
Harakobi EX equation. So the optimal
value function J
is the solution to a partial
differential equation. That seems like
bad news. Partial differential equations
typically are hard to solve.
And so basically if you want to find the
optimal value function J, you had to
solve a partial partial differential
equation because you're taking
derivative with respect to both time and
state. And the solution this partial
differential equation on top of it has a
max mean problem embedded in it. So
looks ugly and actually it's not
particularly pretty but there are
solution algorithms to solve this
partial differential equation. We'll get
to those later. But at least now you
have a mathematical tool that allow to
solve for um the uh value function. And
once you have the value function j then
you get your optimal control u by just
doing an arm max of all this quantity
here. Of course a partial differential
equation as adding differential equation
needs to have a boundary condition which
is represented by your terminal cost.
So I'll come back to this later but
first I want to go back to the setting
of uh standard uh optimal control when
we do not have the distortments. So we
could have done the same thing and it
would have been even simpler. In that
case you get to the continuous time
formulation of the Bman equation which
is still we don't have d anymore because
we are removed the disturbance. So we
are again in a setting where the
dynamics are simply x dot equal f of xu.
We are b now we're in continuous time.
So this is the continuous time
extension to the Bman equation. It is
still a partial differential equation.
You take deres with respect to t and x.
Again you don't hide these because here
we're assuming that [snorts] with there
is no disturbance. But here at least I
can give you an intuition about this
equation represents
and then when I give you intuition you
say oh but this actually is quite
obvious. Specifically
let's rewrite the hamomi bman. So bman
is when we don't have a player two
is when [snorts] we have a player two.
So let me rewrite this equation as minus
partial d with respect to t equal
minimum / u
of g of x u t plus partial derivative of
j with resp to x of f of x u t.
So if you look at this doesn't look like
the Bman equation discrete time
sort of on the right hand side you have
the minimization of a U like in a Bman
equation in discrete time and then
inside you have the immediate reward
or immediate cost depends on how you
interpret this stuff. Um
so let's interpret this as now a cost. I
told you that there's going to be a
little bit of a shift in terminology. So
that's now why we're minimizing over
because we want to make the cost as
small as possible.
And this is the cost to go
and essentially it's telling you how the
cost to go changes as you are moving
your state one step ahead in the
direction of your dynamics. So what is
and this is the partial J respal
to go. So what this equation is telling
you is that minus the time rate of
change of the optimal cost to go is
equal to the uh minimum over u of the
immediate cost plus how your cost will
be changing when choosing the control U.
the state will move into a new state. Of
course, it's not you're not moving into
a new state arbitrarily. You're moving
into the new state following the
dynamics. That's why the derivative is
taking along your dynamics. So in
continuous time, the Bellman equation
takes the notion of a time rate of
change of your cost function while in
discrete time it was a discrete change
across iterations.
Does it shed a bit of light about where
this coming from? So why there is a
minus? Well, we are now in a situation
whereby Jay is interpreted as a cost. We
try to minimize the cost. So as the
horizon shrinks,
there is less cost that you're going to
accumulate until the end of time. And so
your cost is going to decrease as you
move forward in time. So it makes sense
there is a minus.
Just trying to give you guys as much
intuition that I didn't get when these
results were presented to me. And I was
utterly confused about all where all of
this was coming from. So all I'm saying
here is that you shouldn't be too scared
at least from the Atoria Kobe Bman
equation
uh is really very similar to the
discrete time Bman equation. But now
since we're in continuous time, we
reason in terms of time change of uh uh
rates of change of quantities
in time and with respect to how we are
moving our dynamics uh our state around
according to our dynamics
in the adversarial setting. The
intuition is a bit more complicated.
>> Yeah. So kind of saying basically you're
trying to select you to ensure there's
no change in the cost like
>> no no why change in the cost
>> like seems like you're trying to select
you so that you're like
>> no you want to make the change the rate
in terms of time and change as large as
possible so that you decrease the cost
as much as possible
that's why you're minimizing
okay so any questions here. So main
point is that we set up the optimal
control control problem in continuous
time actually in a more general version
where we also consider the possibility
of a second player that is trying to
temper with our objectives. We discuss
how we had to place some assumptions in
terms of how the player two can select
its decisions. We argue how uh a good
model is to assume that the player two
is restricted to take actions that are
not anticipatory. So it can only gets to
see what we have done so far including
the current time. That gives a slight
advantage to player two which is
captured by a specific formulation of
the problem where we do uh a minmax.
Then given that formulation, we invoked
arguments from the principal optimality
to break down that problem into the
solution of a problem whereby we
concatenate current decisions with
optimal decisions
using that insight
then using a first order approximations
with a little bit of magic and proof by
authority where I tell you it's true and
you are not allowed to uh you know
counterargue
uh we derive uh an equation that is
eventually what we care about which is
the HTO Yakobi EX equation for the
differential game formulation of the
problem and the Himeto Yakobi Belman
equation for the more standard version
of the problem where there is no player
two and for the Hamobi Belman equation I
gave you a little bit of intuition
showcasing that even though the equation
looks ugly and it is ugly but it does
have some intuition particularly in
terms of embodying the notion of the t
discrete time bman equation but in terms
of uh uh uh rate of change
that's basically what you should
internalize from here if you want to get
bit deeper about this topic as I said it
gets mathematically quite involved then
I provided some references in the
earlier here
these couple of papers go in much
greater detail about this derivation
Great. So now we have all of these
tools. Let's start applying these tools
first to LQR and later meaning Monday to
a class of problem that is very cool
referred to as reachability
problems. So next time we'll wrap up
this uh lecture with an application to
reachability problems and then we'll
move to MPC. Yeah.
It's a model player two can see the
future one but can
>> see it cannot [clears throat]
assume what like can you see kind of
predict based on what makes more sense
in a fully deterministic setting so
there is no notion of stoastic
prediction
>> yeah there are other formulations but
basically you can have a probabilistic
prediction of what
player one could do but that's not part
of this formulation
>> okay so it's only informed state current
state
>> player It's not history yet.
>> All right. So, let's apply now uh this
stuff to LQR. So, turns out that the
15th version of LQRI we're going to see
in this class is the one in continuous
time. So, now the dynamics are still
linear time varing but uh they are given
by differential equations as opposed to
discrete time equation. The cost is
quadratic but instead of having a
summation now you have an integral.
Same intuition about the parameters for
a QR problem. Q penalizes deviation with
respect to the state. R penalizes
control effort assumed to be positive
definite. This unit TF specified and uh
there are no constraints on the state
and the control.
So can you solve LQR by using the Hobby
Bman equation? Yes, you can. I'm not
going to do the full derivation. It's
not particularly uh insightful.
For those of you that are interested
though, the way that it would work
is as follows. So we know from
uh the discrete time formulation of QR
that the optimal cost to go is a
quadratic in the state. So you start
with an ansat that's how often times you
solve partial differential equation. You
start with an answer, which is basically
the cool mathematical term for a guess,
right? So you start with a guess that
your optimal cost to go is a quadratic
for some matrix V that you do not know.
That's a guess. You plug it into the
partial differential equation and then
you see if there are some conditions on
B that make the partial differential
equation satisfied. So you do a bunch of
boring uh algebraic manipulations and
you'll see that if v is chosen as the
solution of this differential equation
where everything is known so we know q
we know b we know a
um and then we have the boundary
condition at the final time is equal to
h. So if v is solved according to this
differential equation referred to as the
continuous time cut equation then the
partial differential equation the
hamakobi belman partial differential
equation is solved which means that your
guess was correct taking into account
that v is chose as follows. So I mean
quite quick my but main point is that
the way that uh the solution for the QR
will be derived is by guessing what the
optimal cost is parameterized with
respect to a matrix V. Plug it into the
HT Bman equation. See if there is a
appropriate choice of V such that the
partial differential equation is
satisfied because if you know that it is
satisfied indeed the J is the optimal
cost to go. Turns out that if you choose
V as a solution of this ordinary
differential equation, that's indeed the
case. And then the control is given by
surprise surprise linear feedback on the
state now with a slightly different uh
um set of multiplications.
So that's all I wanted to say about LQR.
Main point is that uh you would solve it
still through the lens of dynamic
programming. Now it's a bit more
complicated because we have to solve the
partial differential equation but uh
once you make this guess it's not
actually too complicated and the main
takeaways are that the optimal cost is
still quadratic and the optimal
control is still linear feedback on the
state in the notes you find all the
details
instead what I want to do is to focus
more on applications of differential
games so the differential game
formulations So the formulation where
you also have a player two is actually
quite useful in a number of settings.
There are a number of so-called pursue
evision games. So games similar to the
omicada chauffeur problem that I
mentioned before and a broad um
um
uh set of problems actually are the ones
we're going to focus on are referred to
as reachability problems. And then there
are also many other problems in
economics and such that lead themselves
quite well to differential game
formulation. But in this class I want to
focus a little bit on reachability
analysis that you might have heard
maybe. So inability theory we are
interested in computing the so-called
backward reachable set of a dynamical
system. So this is the set of states
such that the trajectories that start
from this set
are guaranteed to reach a given set at
at the final time TF.
So say that you specify a given set.
The question is if you start one minute
in the in the past what is the set of
initial states such that you are
guaranteed to land into the target set
at the present time.
So again the reachable set backward
reachable set is a set of states such
that trajectories that start from this
set can reach some given target set.
Now depending on how you interpret the
target set that uh you want to reach
then you have different flavors of a
backwardility.
In particular the target set could be
something that you want to avoid. So
basically you want to find the set of
states
that because of an adversarial
um
um choice or controls by player two
would lead to that uh the avoidance set.
Well, you want to then start uh outside
of that set so that you're not
guaranteed to
uh hit an obstacle for example.
So this will be the case of an avoidance
set. So the target set is basically this
when you hit a tree and the blue shape
will encapsulate all those states such
that if you start here
no matter what you do there is going to
be a strategy for the player two. For
example, a fairly for fairly unfortunate
uh sequence of wind gusts that boom will
bring you into the avoidance set. Why is
that useful for control for example for
planning algorithms? Because then you
formulate your planning algorithm such
that you never start from states that
are in within here.
But sometime the target set actually has
a more benign notion. It could be the
set that you want to get into. In the
case we talk about the goal reaching
problems, the backward reachable set now
has the notion of the set of states such
that no matter how player two is trying
to screw us up, we can still reach that
set.
And so for planning purposes, you want
to start inside here.
So depending on how you interpret the
target set, you may want to start as
player one either inside or outside of
it.
Now then the question is how do you
compute these uh sets here depicted in
blue? That's the problem which you
analysis. That's the problem to which we
will apply Hamitoi
Isaac's uh argument. So let me just
state the problem more formally here.
We'll apply the machinery from this
lecture to these problems. Next time I
will also have an interactive script
that will allow us to play a little bit
with these problems.
So to recap the
backward reachable set in the case that
uh the target set corresponds to danger.
So we don't get there is the set of
states Xbar such that there is a player
two strategy
so that no matter what we do as player
one under the joint dynamics we are
going to hit the undesired target at the
final time which is time zero.
Conversely,
the uh
the goal reaching formulation
is so the go reachable set RT is the set
of states such that no matter what
player two is trying to do there exist a
control action as player one that I can
enact such that under the joint dynamics
I'm going to end up in that state. So
I'm happy. So these are the two class of
problems that uh we're going to look at.
So we'll see later we'll see on Monday
how to apply the techniques we discussed
today. It will take about 20 25 minutes.
But you see this is actually quite
useful. You can use it uh quite a bit in
in a variety of robotics applications to
protect yourself from uh obstacles in
sophisticated settings whereby you have
might have disturbances such as wind gas
or other actors. uh or you can apply it
in the setting so that you have very
strong guarantees that you're going to
fulfill your uh objectives.
So to wrap it up, I know that there are
some pieces in this lecture that a bit
harder than usual.
That said, I think it should be clear to
you. The only part that might be a bit
sketchy is the part when we invert the
minimax. If you are interested in
knowing more about that part, either
come to my office hours or have a look
at the two references that I provided in
the second slide.
But it's cool stuff. I mean, you'll see
that actually we'll be doing I will
showing you some interesting examples
with the interactive script that I
actually posted uh on the course
website. So if you're interested, start
playing with it in collab to just get an
appreciation of these tools. All right,
see you on Monday.